kick ass - we have a new trailer for
kick ass - and it's a red band trailer
kinda has to be its kick ass so if you
guys remember I was a huge fan with the
first kick ass movie because I thought
hit girls stole the show - thought the
movie just well it kicked ass and it
looks like kick ass - is gonna bring
honor loyalty and dignity back to the
superhero genre so kick ass - looks to
be what escalation says kick ass -
should be
hey girl and kick ass they joined forces
again and other people have seen these
superheroes do their superhero thing so
there are more superheroes in this movie
and McLovin is back for revenge and he's
building a super villain army and his
super villain name is a super villain in
that can only be said in a red band
trailer in fact it's probably the reason
for the red band trailer
I'm building an evil army the
[ __ ] I like it the Joker's like
why didn't I think of that this is gonna
be the world's first supervillain
[ __ ] so a lot of heroes a lot of
villains a lot of conflict and the cops
are like oh if you're wearing a mask
it's against the law
will arrest you which is a pretty
standard comic-book movie sequel story
arc no kick-ass - isn't directed by
Matthew Vaughn the guy who did the first
one and x-men first class it's written
and directed by the guy who did never
back down which is kind of concerning
but the trailer does show that
apparently he has captured what I did
like about kick-ass which is the
absurdity of it the violence the
crudeness the kick-ass kick-ass hurry
there's no room for Punk's and suits
just real heroes
really keep it all seems to be in here
with a pretty sweet new addition which
is Jim Carrey this guy is America like
the cliched caricature of American
America Stars and Stripes right here Jim
Carrey might still kick ass to like hit
girls still kick ass one and try to have
fun
otherwise support I still want hit girl
to steal the show and kick ass too but I
want to walk out going I don't know who
stole the show more hit girl game on
[ __ ]
Oh Jim Carrey what a good guys sponsor
the dog on your boss so I'm looking
forward to kick ass - there's a big part
of me that wants to be cautiously
optimistic because it has a new writer
and director so we'll see how it goes
but in terms of this trailer I think it
looks kick-ass
so kick-ass - have you seen the trailer
are you looking forward to it are you
cautiously optimistic are you just like
now it's not gonna be as good as the
first one whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more